welcome back so the next week on is Nick
vitam who is going to talk on
exponential Roma Bahn sponsor Factory
Victor usual representations of illegal
goods Thanks I'd like to thank the
organizers of this final workshop for
having me this is joint work with Prasad
Raghavendra's makyo spirit of a and
bench pin bytes so I'm gonna start off
by you know lettings laying some
background and definitions that we've
probably seen many times this week so
the kind of motivation for this work is
studying hyperbolic programming as a
convex programming primitive and as
we've seen there's lots of open
questions on the precise relationship
between hyperbolic programming and
semi-definite programming and there are
some results in this field one such
result is results on complexity of the
representations for specific polynomials
so by complexity of representation here
I mean size of the representation and
the kind of generic question we set out
to answer or partially answer is what
kind of worst-case complexity can we
expect
we all make rigorous in a moment so I'll
be using as a ground set of variables x1
through xn I pulled them as well to be
homogeneous and my degree will be D and
variables so you know we we have hyper
velocity with respect to some direction
e if all linear restrictions in
Direction e are real rooted and with
hyper velocity we get a signified convex
open cone call the hyper velocity cone
and here I've kind of drawn you know the
quintessential example where we are
hyperbolic the direction pointing
upwards and so our cone here is
okay and so the relationship to STPs
which I don't need to belabor is we take
a collection of symmetric matrices and
we form a determinant to polynomial from
them and I do some normalization here
just so I can get the all ones vector to
be in the hyper Felicity cone then this
is a hyperbolic polymer equivalent to
the spectral theorem and the
hypervelocity cone here is a slice of
the cone of STP matrices and so here the
geometric object we're optimizing over
is equivalent to s DPS and so you know
there's a bunch of questions asking kind
of what happens when you take a generic
whatever that might mean
hyperbolic polynomial and some you know
affirmative and negative results in this
area one is Helen Vinick off which says
if you take a trivariate hyperbolic
polynomial it can it be exactly written
as a determinantal polynomial so this
means all trivariate hyperbolic
polynomials you know somehow doing
optimization over them is equivalent to
s dps you know kind of influenced or
inspired by the the geometric relaxation
of this one might try to take radicals
of this so you can see that once you go
past try variate dimension counting
shows you can't get to determinate
diploma mills anymore you also can't you
can find explicit examples frontend
constructed one where even taking high
powers won't yield the determinantal
representation and so then we have this
geometric relaxation
we can't encode our polynomial itself as
the determinantal polynomial can we look
at the geometric space we're optimizing
over and say that those are equivalent
that all hyper Blissey cones are in fact
slices of the SDP code this is open
but this is something like a qualitative
statement this says that if I want to do
hyperbolic programing the geometric sets
I'm optimizing over can always be
written as the same geometric sets I'm
optimizing over in an ST piece but it's
not a quantitative statement it doesn't
say anything about the relative
complexity of these representations so
even if I did get this I could end up
maybe it's a naive hope but one could
end up with a problem which is easy to
optimize over and hyperbolic land and
you can you know you can say okay sure
the hyper Blissey cone is an SCP but
maybe that SCP is exponential doubly
exponential etc and so hard to optimize
over in the s SDP world
another result that's quite nice here is
it's known that if you have a smooth
hypervelocity cone which is just some
generic Ness assumption that they can be
written as projections of spectra huge
slices of the spectra heat'll are sorry
slices of spectra hedron's so this gives
us some nice generic result but it's
still projections it's not exactly
okay so let's talk about complexity
which is what I'm interested in this
talk so for some explicit classes of
polynomials people have constructed
spectral representations of varying
sizes any question is kind of how what's
the smallest you can get if I give you a
polynomial what's the small speck you
draw representation I can realize it
does so an example of this is if you
take the elementary symmetric
polynomials I'll be talking about a lot
in this talk
Rondon show that there's an
exponentially sized partido
representation for them so the question
is what are the worst-case scenarios if
I give you a kind of random hyperbolic
polynomial what do I expect the size of
the spec sheet or presentation to be so
you get an expected he'd representation
to me is a bunch of matrices where I can
write the the hypervelocity cone as the
hypervelocity counter the determinant of
the sum XIII and so by complexity I mean
the size of these matrices how big
what's the smallest matrices I can find
to encode this geometric object okay
theorem the wording isn't very
particular hopefully I'll give you the
essence of it and it says that we we
find a family of polynomials of
increasing degree and number of
variables such that if there are
spectral he'd representations for these
polynomials they have to be
exponentially large
so if you want this exact result as I
just said it there's an algebraic way to
do this pointed out by Cynthia Van Zandt
our proof is analytic so we get
something a little bit more for free
which is not only do we find a family of
polynomials which have exponentially
size particular representations but also
any approximate property over
representation also has to be
exponentially large so this is what
we're gonna set out to proof the main
theorem our paper so the rest of talk
will be me kind of stepping through how
we got got to this result and I think
there's some nice machinery along the
way that can be applied elsewhere it's
kind of we quickly reach some challenges
on how to study a specific objects and I
think there's a lot of work to be done
here so hopefully some of these
techniques will help yeah yeah so I can
talk on that more on the end but that's
a great question yeah so a really
natural question is can you come up with
an explicit family of polynomials that
would be really fantastic I mean a great
candidate would be the elementary
symmetric polynomials we're gonna end up
taking small perturbations of the
elementary symmetric polynomials so yeah
it'd be really nice if you could show an
exact problem and it does like beg the
question you know okay you've shown that
there's this family of polynomials which
has exponentially sized spectra he drew
them but can you say anything about them
being nice in the hyperbolic world and
the answer is no not yet
okay so what are the objects I'm
interested in in this talk I have my
hyperbolic polynomials associated to my
hyper block polynomials I have the
geometric object which is my hyperbola
city cones open convex cones and then
associated hyperbola C cones
I have spectra he'd show representations
which I'm thinking of as tuples of
matrices
two matrices AI okay so some of these
spaces are nice some of these maps are
nice some of these spaces aren't nice
some of these mats aren't nice
so hyper block polynomials pretty well
behaved it's a sub we viewed as a subset
of homogeneous polynomials of degree D
it's known that it had this set has
non-empty interior and so this is a nice
set it's an open set within just the set
of polynomials it has dimension
exponential and indeed hyperbola city
cones less well behaved so now we're
looking at the space of all open convex
cones containing one harder to say stuff
about this space for example questions
of dimensionality respect to huge
representations if you get I'm thinking
of as n-tuples of B by B symmetric
matrices see here is the eventual size
of this petrified representations I'm
ending up with so a very nice space and
it has well understood dimension and so
kind of what would be the goal the goal
would be if all of this behave nicely
and was you know locally injective and
the such then we'd have some exponential
size space here we could take some open
ball here push it over push it over end
up with some open ball here and that's
going to give us lower bounds on B since
the the final space dimension is
polynomial and B and the first space
dimension is exponential and in D that
should say that B has to be pretty large
but there's some problems with this I
mean a this space is not so nice and B
this this map I haven't constructed I
don't even know if it exists it's you
know the map that said every
hypervelocity cone has a spectral
representation so we can't really assume
anything about that
so what are we gonna do instead well we
we really only want some crude estimate
here and so what we're gonna do is a
packing argument so what do I mean by
packing argument well if I'm sitting
over here in my nice Euclidean space and
I have you know double the exponentially
points that are not too close together
and live in some bounded ball it's not
growing too quickly then by some just
trivial a volume argument I'm gonna get
some bound in the dimension I'm gonna be
able to say well all of my points are
have some minimal distance and so I can
put a small ball around them measure
their volume and then I have the volume
of the overall the overall sphere and
that's gonna give me some way to control
the size of B and the the benefit of
this is I don't need to use any kanuha T
or differentiability along the way I can
just explicitly find some small
collection of hyperbolic polynomials map
them over under these two maps and what
do I really need to show I really need
to show that they're paranoid distances
don't get too close and at the end
they're in some bounded ball so that's
going to be the essence of our approach
we ended up constructing a hypercube of
hyperbolic polynomials and this is the
most challenging step so this is well
kind of belabor the most it has some
nice ideas in it once you have this
hypercube of hyperbolic polynomials you
have to somehow show the hyper Lucy
cones don't get too close
somewhat challenging but not too hard
and then the final step is quite easy as
we'll see clear
okay and one of the nice things about
this approach is we have a lot of
flexibility kind of the dimension of our
starting space needs to be X mention on
N and D which equates that be having
doubly exponential 8 points in nad but
the the distances don't get too close so
I have a lot of flexibility basically
it's allowed to be singly exponentially
close it just can't get EE exponentially
close and so because of this we get very
kind of crude approaches everywhere we
go because as long as we're not picking
up a double exponential factor in
shrinking between our you know from our
polynomials to our cones and our coasts
of spectral representations in the end
we'll have the boundary one so there's a
lot of flexibility in this which is
waiting so let's look at the elementary
symmetric polynomial so I'm just gonna
kind of quickly define it for those who
may be unfamiliar so the elementary
symmetric polynomial in n variables a
degree D is the sum of all monomials of
size D from the ground set it's multi
affine meaning that it no term shows up
with power to all terms show up with
power at most one and there's another
way to see it which will prove fruitful
in a moment
so if we take the the elementary
symmetric polynomial of degree n in n
variables it's just this
just a single monomial containing all of
the variables and I take iterated
directional derivatives in the all ones
direction then I will end up in the end
with the elementary symmetric polynomial
degree D and this is nice because this
immediately shows that the elementary
symmetric polynomial degree C is
hyperbolic so if you take directional
derivatives with respect to a vector and
high publicity cone we preserve high
publicity basically just because
directional derivative will correspond
to a univariate rivet ivana linear
restrictions and since my linear
restrictions are real rooted the
derivatives are real rooted so therefore
the directional derivative preserves
hyper Blissey so somehow I like to think
of the elementary symmetric polynomial
as this canonical hyper block polynomial
but it turns out it lives on the
boundary of hyper vlogged polynomials
and it's not too hard to see this so I
think it's fruitful to think about it so
the boundary of the set of hyperbolic
polynomials has been characterized the
boundary of the set of hyper boats so
what does the hyper block polynomial
it's one in which when we look at all
the new restrictions in some fixed
direction it's real rooted and so what's
the boundary it's when one of these
linear restrictions has a root of
multiplicity so we're in the interior of
the space of hyperbolic polynomials when
all of our linear restrictions are
simple rooted and so the question is for
which elementary symmetric polynomials
do I have a restriction that has a
multiple root and it's not that hard to
see because of this observation that you
know my directional derivative is
commuting or kind of quote-unquote
commuting with univariate derivative on
the restrictions and so then my you know
my restriction for the elementary
symmetric polynomial degree D will have
a repeated root if and only if at the
very top I had a root of multiplicity n
minus D plus two and it's not hard to
see here that when we're looking at the
multiplicity of restrictions of en
what's going to happen
well the roots are gonna be exactly the
coordinates my vector and so this
restriction will have root of
multiplicity n minus D plus two if and
only if n minus D plus two the
coordinates are the same it's going to
happen whenever D is greater than two
we're gonna go find examples of that if
you're greater than two elementary
symmetric polynomials on the boundary
side of hyperbolic monomials and this is
a bit of a bummer because if we wanted
to just kind of generically do this
argument we would take the elementary
symmetric polynomial and we do random
perturbations around it we'd say these
random perturbations behave nicely the
hypervelocity cones are you know far
apart and we keep going we can't do
random perturbations because we're on
the boundary so we need to be more
clever with our perturbations and that's
what we do we find a collection of
perturbations that will stay hyperbolic
but these restrictions these troublesome
restrictions are really what we're going
to focus on so I'm gonna call these
restrictions where n minus D plus two of
the coordinates of X are the same
troublesome or high multiplicity or
whatnot and so one neither necessary nor
sufficient condition but nice condition
would be if we pick perturbations which
vanish on these restrictions these
restrictions are riveted polynomials
with roots of high multiplicity and now
we want to perturb them so one nice
thing would just be if our multivariate
polynomial on these restrictions was
identically zero we wouldn't have to
worry about maybe perturbing the
polynomial and introducing complex roots
another neither necessary or sufficient
condition is to find multivariate
polynomials which we're going to perturb
our elementary symmetric polynomial by
such that their translation invariant in
the all ones direction what do I mean by
that so what do I want to do I want to
take the elementary symmetric polynomial
I want to perturb it a bit I want to end
up with a hyper block polynomial so if I
have translation invariance in the all
ones direction then that means that when
I'm looking at a linear restriction of
this which I want to be real rooted for
all X
by translation invariance this only
depends on X and a little bit longer
depends on T so it's a polynomial in T
I'm just taking this this restriction
and I'm shifting the plot up or down and
so the question becomes kind of what can
I say about Q of X in terms of my
elementary symmetric polynomial in order
to keep it real rooted so it's kind of
hard to see but this is the the x axis
right here and so I have this real
rooted polynomial and the question is
how much can I add to it how much what's
the magnitude of a constant I can add to
it to keep it real rooted well the
answer is I can add to it until I hit my
first critical point and so I need Q of
X to be bounded by the magnitude of my
polynomial ax at its critical points
we're in here translation invariance
means I can shift this critical point of
this graph to be at zero and so we get
this perturbation criteria we get a
sufficient criteria for the kind of
perturbations that will preserve
hypervelocity
[Music]
yeah so what I mean by perturb it is I
mean so I guess the question I'm
explicitly asking is what is a condition
on Q such that ETA X plus Q of X so oh
yeah I can't perturb it in all
directions but I can and so this is
sufficient criteria and it might look a
little wonky right now but it turns out
to have kind of a nice qualitative
analogue that we'll see in a moment but
yeah so II D minus one is the derivative
of our restriction and so when we what
we want is we want to somehow bound our
perturbation by the elementary symmetric
polynomial win the previous elementary
symmetric polynomial vanishes and I'm
not going to go into why this implies
this but one consequence of this
criteria is that if X has n minus D plus
two coordinates then Q of X is 0 so yet
again we have what we want this nice
property that our perturbations vanish
on the Troublesome restrictions getting
that's not sufficient
okay so I'm going to kind of pull some
perturbations out of thin air here so
given a D matching on my index set which
maybe looks like this so here and is I
guess nine I have this D matching where
D is three I can construct a polynomial
which is just a product of the
differences along the pairs and I claim
if X has n minus D plus two the same
coordinates in this must vanish so
that's like sanity check number one we
want it to vanish on the Troublesome
coordinates and this is not too hard to
see if I I've indicated here the red
ones I how all have the same coordinate
there's n minus 2 D coordinates here and
there D pairs if at any point this
happens i vanish because i have two of
the same coordinates on the same pair
which means their corresponding term
will vanish and so if i have n minus 2 d
here that's fine and then i have one for
each of my D pairs I end up with n minus
D the minute I get above that it's gonna
vanish
notice that this polynomial is
homogeneous degree D it's also
translation invariant if I add TI to or
T all ones to this it doesn't change it
and so we get a span of perturbations
quote-unquote perturbations which vanish
on the Troublesome restrictions be it
again as was pointed out you know we're
on the boundary so these are not all
going to be hyperbolic so another plane
is small versions of these are
hyperbolic so I wanted to remind us of
our perturbation criteria
no they're the same degree yeah yeah so
I'm looking at the alimentary small
symmetric polynomial degree D and since
this is a D matching okay so I need to
somehow quantify the distance I just
pick some so how do I do that I picked
some basis on the span of these and this
choice of basis will be important later
but for now pick any basis and I look at
I look at a perturbation by just looking
at its coordinates in that basis and I'm
just gonna pick some metric so I'm gonna
look at the l1 metric so it's known that
the span of all these polynomials has
dimension n choice D - and choose D
minus 1 which is good for us because
that means that this subspace we found
is still high enough dimension still
exponential antenna D which is what we
wanted right like we we want to show
that somehow the exponential the fact
that the space of homogeneous
polynomials is exponentially sized
implies the space inspector he draw
representations is exponentially sized
but we we say oh we run into a problem
where on the boundary and so we might
not be able to find kind of a half ball
that is a high enough dimension it turns
out we can so that's nice and just using
the triangle inequality you know we need
this bound we need this we need to
somehow say something about Q of X for
all X not just X where n minus T plus
through the same coordinates are the
same we can bound q of X in terms of
this quantity and this quantity is the
max over all subsets of size D of the
norm of the product of those coordinates
it's how are we gonna relate these and
so this is kind of my intuition for this
all this that's happening so this is a
nice little problem if you have a real
vector X and the elementary symmetric
ownio degree D and the elementary
similar symmetric polynomial degree D
minus 1 vanish when you plug in X then X
has n minus D plus 2 zero coordinance
this corresponds to the fact that if you
have a real rooted polynomial and two of
the inner coefficients adjacent to each
other are 0 then all the ones after that
have to be 0 you know if I log in cavity
or but not and so the question is can I
get an analytic continuation of this
what if I force et minus 1 to be 0 and
now I want to say something about n
minus D plus 2 Z coordinates are really
close to 0 if Edie is really small and
so this is the main technical lemma of
our paper turns out to be a bit of a
pain but you can so if you this was the
quantity that showed up on the previous
slide and it somehow is measuring this
this idea and this says that if we have
a real vector which vanishes it's d
minus 1 degree elementary symmetric
polynomial vanishes then we can control
the max of any the max absolute value of
any monomials of size D so any of the
minimum is showing up in the elementary
symmetric polynomial we can control its
magnitude with the elementary symmetric
polynomial degree D so notice for
example if this is 0 this implies that
this is 0 which implies that every
subset of size D has a is the the norm
of it the product is 0 it implies one of
these is 0 for each of them which gives
you n minus T plus two of them have to
be 0 so this is a generalization of this
kind of and we only knew how to prove
this using kind of machinery using real
root of polynomials so we do the same
thing
okay so all this to say bye-bye getting
this found it's uh it's it's exponential
but we we were okay with that we were
okay with exponential shrinking we're
not okay with doubly exponential
shrinking and it satisfies our
perturbation criteria so it gives us
some idea then of this epsilon needed to
stay hyperbolic so what were the
takeaways there was a lot of kind of
technical things the main takeaways are
we found a space a subspace of
perturbations which is still
exponentially sized still exponential
and dimension and we've shown that for
small enough perturbations we're still
hyperbolic in one direction um and so we
we construct this hypercube of
hyperbolic polynomials where we just you
know with our basis pick a bit strings
your own one and then we add epsilon
perturbations in that direction one
that's the most technical part I promise
okay given perturbations how do we make
meaningful statements about hyper plus
income how everybody cones are not the
best things to deal with I'm not gonna
belabor this we picked some metric house
tour distance house or stiff house tour
distance is uh asymmetric so we
symmetrized it and the general idea is
pick pick a vector of norm one in one of
your cones and look at its distance to
the other cone find the max distance
among all this so one nice thing about
this definition is it turns out as I'll
kind of show you with picture proof that
we can show two cones are far apart if
we show they're far apart on a linear
restriction we do like when you're
restrictions because we're dealing with
hyperbolic polynomials after all but we
need to be able to say something
meaningful about our restrictions so you
know I ended up with this this hyper
cube of polynomials and it's not clear
that's going to be very easy to analyze
they're hyper blue C cones or anything
about their restrictions and so yeah so
our goal is to pick some restrictions we
pick indicator functions on D variables
in the index set and then when we take
two of my hyperbola seed cones
corresponding to two of my poem those of
my hypercube I want to find a
restriction for which they're far enough
apart and then I want to argue that that
means they're hyper plus d cones are far
apart okay so you thought we remember
are all of our restrictions are shifting
and so
we have for any given restriction this
because our linear restriction are all
of our perturbations are translation
invariant um and so this is just some
constant and we're looking specifically
at the linear restrictions on the
indicator functions and so it'd be nice
if we can control this this is just some
constant it'd be nice if we could have
some guarantees on it and so one
question is when I take this these
indicator functions and I have my
matching I'm filling in my my
coordinates with D 1 s and the rest
zeroes win is this non vanishing well if
any two of these are it pulls a zero it
vanishes and any two of these are both
with one advantages and so it's not
vanishing exactly when my subset s
touches each of my matchings or the each
of the edges am i matching exactly once
so we call this fully crossing and
basically we take a further restriction
of our space so we don't use all of our
perturbations we pick a subset of
perturbations such that for any given
matching there is some restriction on
which it doesn't vanish and it's the
only such matching on for which on that
restriction it doesn't vanish and we're
really abusing the fact we have a lot of
flexibility here we only need W
exponentially points so we can cut off
these factors as much as we like
Clemmie but this is kind of the goal so
I end up with two points in this
hypercube polynomials and you know they
have two completely different bit
strings and I want to be able to compare
them all depending regardless of which
pair of points polynomials I picked I
want to be able to compare the
restrictions equally and this allows us
to do this because now if I take any two
different bit strings they there are
different bit strings so they differ on
some matching polynomial we've picked
and on that matching polynomial we can
find a restriction for which all the
other terms in my son vanish and for one
of my bit strings it doesn't vanish if
the other one it does and so now the
regardless of which pairs I picked
appoints in my hypercube I found a
restriction where it looks the same up
to symmetry furthermore the Jacobi
polynomial pops up so when we look at
these linear restrictions we have the
Jacobi polynomial and so we have this
picture where a long just linear
restriction I have a Jacobi polynomial
the max fruit is here and for my other
hypervelocity cone it's the max fruit of
taking the Jacobi polynomial and
shifting it by Epsilon so I just need to
study the effect to the largest root of
the Jacobi polynomial by shifting it by
Epsilon so this really big chunk of text
which is this technical umm I couldn't
figure out how to make intuitive just
says that we can treat all pairs equally
if I take any two pairs of polynomials
in my hyper cube we can view them the
same okay well that's great null but how
do I actually get distance on the cones
well it's not all that bad once I have
distance on the restrictions because all
my pairs look the same I only have to
analyze one set up and now I just need
to say that somehow when I I project and
I and I find this tangent plane to my
convex cone things are not so bad but
all I need to show is that the hyper the
hyperplane didn't move too much so if
this is the hyper plane of the Jacobi
polynomial the choral Jacobi polynomial
I can analyze this directly and this is
the perturbation that showed doesn't
move too much with fun
okay so where are we now we had W
exponentially many hyperbolic
polynomials in this hypercube we wanted
to show that when we look at their hyper
Blissey cones they don't get too close
together and we managed managed to do
that by looking at nice restrictions
finally spectral representations
so we have this idea of normalized
spectral representations so expect to
eat all representation it's just to sum
as a determinant of polynomial and we're
gonna call them normalized if the plot
the matrices that show up are positive
semi-definite and they sum to the
identity and it's not hard to show that
if you give me a spectral representation
and spectra detail cone contains the
positive or thin then I can normalize
this factors usual representation to end
up with one of these normalized spectral
representations but which hypervelocity
cones contain the positive Worthen well
I have a polynomial with all
non-negative coefficients that has the
all ones vector as a hypervelocity
vector then because it has non-negative
coefficients
it doesn't vanish in the positive were
thin and therefore contains the positive
or thin as a hyperbola C cone are we in
this scenario yes so we're looking at
perturbations of the elementary
symmetric polynomial and the key
observation is that these are all multi
affine the elementary symmetric
polynomial contains every term possible
on a multi offline polynomial with
coefficient one and we're just
perturbing those coefficients by a small
small amount and so we're just gonna
take all these coefficients which are
one and we're gonna probe them by
epsilon so we're gonna end up with a non
negative polynomial and therefore all of
the polynomials we're looking at have
non-negative coefficients all they're
hypervelocity cones containing the
positive or with it so we can assume
their spectra Ito representations are
normalized
I'm not going to belabor this but you
know this is a easy exercise that shows
that if you have cones that are
sufficiently far apart that implies that
the matrices have to be sufficiently far
apart and kind of pick your favorite
matrix metric that gets us where we need
to be we constructed doubly
exponentially mini hyperbolic
polynomials we showed that there was a
sufficient gap between them such that
they were still hyperbolic we showed
that the hypervelocity cones maintained
a big enough gap and that the spectral
representations also maintained that gap
and so in the end we end up with EE
exponentially spectra Ito
representations the distance between
them doesn't shrink too much and by that
I mean it's just singly exponential and
the ball that contains them we didn't
really talk much about that but because
they're normalized they're contained in
some trivial ball that's growing
polynomial E and so we get some we get
the same kind of exponential dimension
by pushing the packing argument through
okay future directions which we're kind
of already mentioned so one one
direction is it's known as I mentioned
that smooth hyperbola see cones are
projections of large specter Hydra what
what is a worst-case scenario in this
case can we can we say something
generically for all these smooth
hypervelocity cones
another question is can we find an
explicit polynomial that would be really
desirable especially if that explicit
polynomial was nice in the regard that
it had low complexity and hyperbolic
programming
[Applause]
any questions
your precise statement about
how far
they come like the approximation
you mean when we're following this
argument through yeah but we were
middlee pretty sloppy in this because we
were only running after this exponential
bound at the end so for example like
this key technical lemma which was the
main pain I don't think this is tight I
don't have any this is you know we're
getting some exponential loss here and
who knows how far you could push this
it's I think this is a really
interesting notion in general where you
you have this qualitative statement that
says if two coefficients in your real
root of polynomial adjacent coefficient
Spanish then the rest of them do and so
you have this high multiplicity and you
ask if you take one of those
coefficients and it vanishes and you
take the next one and it's small what
can you say about quote-unquote
multiplicity but it's unclear to me that
MD is even necessarily the natural
object to study yes we do is so we have
these these bounds throughout the paper
which tell us how this stuff this matter
the bound is what we end to the minus
and beat looks really thing yeah
any more comments questions
lastly you mentioned that this space of
capitalistic homes are couldn't I should
I should have made it qualify that
they're bad to me because I don't know
how to deal with I'm sure somebody would
look at this and just say oh that's a
very natural space and as some probably
natural ways to deal with things but I
guess maybe I mean bad relative to the
space of tuples of matrices and
homogeneous polynomials which are both
kind of very easy to work in ya know I
think the question was is there a
natural metric to put on it and if there
is or isn't like do you have some notion
of dimension we even be just looking at
the space of all open convex cones that
contain one probably not I mean probably
there's some smaller space in which the
hypervelocity cones live that maybe it's
easier to deal with
and more comments
let's thank him again resuming in half
now